emma watson has had quite a busy career
over the years
in more ways than one most recognized
watson from her first ever
acting role as the wise beyond her years
witch
for myani granger in the harry potter
film series
which ran from 2001 to 2011. in the year
since
however watson has become so much more
than the wand-wielding character who
launched her into the spotlight and made
her a household name at a very young age
not only has watson gone on to star in
films like the perks of being a
wallflower
playing sam button opposite logan lerman
and the flash actor ezra miller
and the bling ring a project that
allowed her to play a not so good
character for the first time
but she has also lent her talents and
international fame to various
humanitarian causes as well
that includes being named a united
nations women goodwill ambassador
spearheading the he for she campaign and
modeling for burberry among other
notable fashion brands
as one would expect devoting so much of
her time to causes outside the film
industry
doesn't leave much room in her schedule
having not appeared in a big screen
production since starring as
margaret meg march in director greta
gerwig's 2019 hit little women
an adaptation of the luisa may alcott
1868 novel of the same name
watson has left her devoted fans to
wonder whether she might possibly be
looking to cut down her time in front of
the camera
or perhaps step away from acting
altogether this prospect became even
more of a talking point when the daily
mail published a report on february 20th
2021
that speculated on watson's potential
retirement from acting
thankfully watson's manager has come out
and put the final word on this ongoing
saga
spoiler alert the word is good in the
daily mail's original write-up it was
reported that watson's agent
apparently said she has gone quote
dormant and that her publicist
reportedly confirmed
she is not taking on new commitments an
anonymous source of the daily mail
further alleged that watson would likely
be settling down with her boyfriend
rumored to be her fiance leo robinson
whom
she has been dating for the last year
and a half the source claimed
emma has gone underground she is
settling down with leo
they're laying low maybe she wants a
family understandably this sent many of
watson's fans into a tailspin
taking to social media to express their
dismay at the idea of watson giving up
acting forever
one fan wrote on twitter emma watson is
retiring
i'm genuinely so upset she was my hero
when i was younger
hermione meant everything to me another
added
emma watson is retiring i am well and
truly heartbroken
luckily for those who've loved watson's
work since her days at hogwarts
and those who only recently dove into
her filmography alike
the reports that she's retiring aren't
true on february 25th
2021 watson's manager jason weinberg
of untitled entertainment issued a
statement to entertainment weekly that
put everyone at ease
weinberg said emma's social media
accounts are dormant but her career
isn't weinberg didn't address the claims
that watson isn't currently looking for
new projects to take on
and that she's looking to slow the pace
of her life down in order to spend more
time with robinson
but really that information isn't
anyone's business
if she wants to put a pause on reading
auditioning for and accepting more movie
and even television roles for the time
being that's her prerogative
the same goes for how she chooses to
prioritize what seems to be a very
important romantic relationship
when watson will return to the silver
screen or her various
social media platforms remains to be
seen at any rate
she's one of the hardest working
individuals in hollywood and certainly
fills her plate with other ventures and
fields beyond acting and entertainment
as evidenced by the numerous causes she
continually advocates for
if watson chooses to take some time away
from the hustle and bustle of show
business
to recharge and refocus she should feel
free to do so
there's no denying that watson deserves
it and there's no denying that when
she makes her much anticipated big
screen return
in whatever movie she takes on next
watson will be celebrated with
thunderous applause
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite actors are coming soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one